PAUL IRISH: So thank
you for joining us.
We're going to be talking about
the Chrome Developer
Tools and what sort of new
features are available.
Covering everything that's kind
of happened in the past
six months or anything that you
haven't known about, but
good stuff.
So the way that I want to get it
started is introducing who
we have here in this Hangout.
I'm Paul Irish.
I'm on the Chrome Developer
relations team.
And I like the Chrome Developer
tools quite a bit.
We also have joining
us Pavel Feldman.
Pavel is the tech lead of
Chrome Developer Tools.
Say hello.
PAVEL FELDMAN: Hey.
PAUL IRISH: Cool.
Also on the Chrome team,
we have Sam Dutton
coming in from London.
SAM DUTTON: How are
you doing, guys?
Good to see you.
PAUL IRISH: Nice.
And also over there,
Peter Beverloo.
PETER BEVERLOO: Hey,
good morning.
PAUL IRISH: Nice.
If you haven't checked out
peter.sh, it's a great blog
coming with weekly updates on
what's happening inside Chrome
and WebKit and the Chrome
Dev tools in particular.
So that's a great source for
what's new and breaking in
Chrome Dev Tools land.
We also have with
us Alex Sexton.
ALEX SEXTON: Howdy.
PAUL IRISH: Alex is a JavaScript
and front-end
developer down in
Austin, Texas.
And we're looking to get one
more developer with us pretty
soon, Paul Lewis.
We hope to see him joining us.
But we'll get started now.
Nice.
Is that Paul?
PAUL LEWIS: Yo.
PAUL IRISH: Oh, great.
Paul, we were just finishing
up introductions.
So Paul Lewis, based over in--
you in the UK now?
PAUL LEWIS: I'm in
London, yeah.
PAUL IRISH: London, perfect.
Paul is a WebGL, CSS3, 3D
transforms, GPU, JavaScript
hacker, making cool, fun,
awesome, creative stuff.
So the way that we're going to
go about this, we have a
Google Moderator with a bunch
of questions that you could
vote up and down.
That you should see that in
the Google+ posts that we
have. You can click over
there and vote up
other people's questions.
Vote down them if you don't want
to hear us cover that.
And ask anything that you want
to get an answer to.
And if that sounds good,
we'll get started.
So in the Chrome Developer
Tools, I just
have them open here.
And we're going to walk through
some of the things
that are new.
One thing that I should point
out is we do have the ability
to zoom the UI, which is really
handy for this use case
of showing you guys.
So now if you hit Command Plus,
Command Minus, it zooms
the entire thing.
This works out really well for
projecting or anything else.
So if you haven't looked at
the Dev Tools in about six
months, you might not have
noticed down in the very
bottom right is a little
settings cog.
And down here, the Chrome
Developer Tools' own settings.
One of the nice things in here
is the ability to override the
user agent.
And so now we can set the user
agent to be one of any of
these predefined other browsers
or define our own
user agent that we want
Chrome to mask as.
And so [INAUDIBLE]
the navigator dot user agent
JavaScript property, but also
the user agent that goes out
in the Request tab here.
So it's a complete end to
end UA masking solution.
Another setting right beneath
this, and this is brand new,
is emulate touch events.
And so if you've done mobile
work before, you might have
been frustrated with the fact
that you can't do real touch
events on desktop, and you
always have to be using a
mobile device and fire
up your emulator.
So now we can emulate touch
events right in Chrome.
So to show off this, I'm going
to bring up a little demo.
So this is just a little
canvas app.
And as you touch it, it draws.
Inside my browser right now, I'm
clicking all over and it's
not doing anything.
But if I bring up the Chrome
Developer Tools and I have the
Dev Tools open with the settings
checked, all the
touch start, touch end, touch
move events are emulated.
So I get exactly the kind
of behavior that I want.
Pretty nice.
Good.
Pavel, did you want to talk a
little bit about the color
picker that's now available?
PAVEL FELDMAN: Yeah, that's
something new that we have. It
is interesting, because it's
a third party contribution.
And we are happy about third
parties contributing code into
the Web Inspector in
Chrome Dev Tools.
So if you try to click the
little color swatch, the color
picker will show up.
It shows you the gradient and
you can adjust transparency
through these [INAUDIBLE]
channel.
And as you are adjusting the
transparency, you'll see how
the background is visible
through the
color that you've chosen.
So it's pretty essential.
SAM DUTTON: Pavel, can you still
get at the selected for
changing the representation
of the color?
PAVEL FELDMAN: Right, right.
The Control click will be
[INAUDIBLE] different formats.
PAUL IRISH: Control click.
I was wondering about that.
Control click.
PAVEL FELDMAN: Now Control click
on the swatch in the
list down here.
And the [INAUDIBLE] can adjust
this alpha slider, and you
will see the background.
Try adjusting this alpha
slider, and look
at the color preview.
You don't actually need to have
any [? background ?] yet.
Just move this thing.
Yeah, you will see a little
chessboard thingy.
I don't need the color
in the preview.
PAUL IRISH: Nice.
So the Color Picker's been a big
request for a long time.
So we're very happy to
have that available.
So one of the things you might
have also noticed in this view
is that the check boxes
are now on the left.
So this has been a big request
for a long time, of these
check boxes to disable these
styles have been on the right
for the longest time.
And a lot of people have
felt it makes more
sense on the left.
So now if you open a Chrome
Canary, they're on the left.
So Pavel put this in
about last week.
And we hope you'll like that.
PAVEL FELDMAN: And it
was [INAUDIBLE]
over a two-year struggle.
This and the single
click, right.
PAUL IRISH: Yeah, it's
a single click.
For the longest time in the
Chrome Developer Tools if you
want to change, for instance,
any of these properties, like
I want to change font size from
small to large, I had to
double click.
And it would go into this
edit mode, and then I
could change that.
Now it's only a single click
to make that change.
So it's a lot more malleable.
It's very nice.
Cool.
Any newcomers?
So we're just walking through
some of the features with
Chrome Developer Tools
and the new stuff.
We have a Google Moderator.
And if you want to ask any
questions, please just load up
questions or ask any new
ones over there.
Sam, is there anything in the
Moderator that you think we
should talk about right now?
SAM DUTTON: Yeah,
there sure is.
We've got a stack of stuff
coming in on Moderator.
PAUL IRISH: Great.
SAM DUTTON: Yeah, blimey.
Where to start?
OK, well I'll start
at the top.
The most popular question
we've had so
far, I think, is--
well it's a big one, asking if
we could walk through tracking
down a memory leak in a
page or an extension
using the Heap Profiler.
PAUL IRISH: Sure, good one.
SAM DUTTON: Go for it.
PAUL IRISH: So I'm going
to bring up this.
Pavel, feel free to interrupt
me as I go along with this.
We have a little
test page here.
And if we look at the source of
the test page, we've got a
few things going on.
We have an array.
And we have a button.
And when it's clicked, we're
going to do this.
We're going to create a new P.
And we're going to add that
into the page.
And add that into our
holding array.
And after a little bit,
we're going clear
out the page's content.
So what this looks
like is that.
Just adding it.
The page is being cleared.
But what you'll notice in
something like Timeline is
that the memory usage just
continues to go up.
And the garbage collection
never cuts that
memory usage back down.
And this right here is an
indication that you might be
encountering a memory leak.
So I'll try and go through
how we can identify
where this leak is.
So we go over to Profiles,
and we're going
to take a Heap Snapshot.
PAVEL FELDMAN: Didn't notice
it if you start the
Timeline, did you?
PAUL IRISH: Timeline
is still recording.
OK, Snapshot done.
ALEX SEXTON: Perhaps there's
a memory leak in
the Snapshot tool.
PAUL IRISH: Oh.
I'm going to try and go
ahead with the action.
So if we've identified in the
Timeline tool that there is
increasing memory usage,
I'm now going to- oh,
we have zero bytes.
I might have to try this over in
Chrome Stable in a moment.
PAVEL FELDMAN: No, no.
Go back to the Canary.
PAUL IRISH: You like it?
PAVEL FELDMAN: Yeah.
Just try clearing it up and
collecting another one.
Don't do anything.
Just collect [INAUDIBLE]
PAUL IRISH: Ooh, that's
much better.
PAVEL FELDMAN: I wonder how
much you have used.
PAUL IRISH: How much what?
PAVEL FELDMAN: How
much Heap site?
How big Heap is?
Because it takes too long.
It should take this much time
for the Gmail, not for the say
hello thingy.
PAUL IRISH: Ouch.
Yeah.
Let's try one more.
So I'm going to give
this a shot.
I'm going to hit the
button five times.
And we're going to record
another Heap Snapshot.
And then we're going to go
over to comparison mode.
Pavel, are we seeing
what we want?
PAVEL FELDMAN: No.
And this doesn't look
like Stable to me.
Is it?
PAUL IRISH: No, it's
not Stable.
PAVEL FELDMAN: Now that's
a [INAUDIBLE]
PAUL IRISH: All right,
over in Stable.
One two, three, four, five.
Another Snapshot.
Clicking over to the second
Snapshot and changing our mode
to comparison.
ALEX SEXTON: Yay.
PAUL IRISH: It's good.
Pavel.
PAVEL FELDMAN: Don't
look at me.
You have all of these chaps
doing something to the left.
PAUL IRISH: Something.
Something going on.
So what I'm used to seeing is
capturing a delta of five.
Associating my five clicks with
five new items and being
able to track--
it's actually a paragraph
element--
paragraph element back to
that holding array.
Ah, here we go.
Yep.
So here we are basically seeing
the paragraph elements
that were created and their
retaining path back to
holding down here.
So essentially tracking through
the Timeline tool.
[INAUDIBLE]
PAUL IRISH: We good?
Nice.
SAM DUTTON: You're
back on air.
PAUL IRISH: Good.
All right, so I'm going to move
on from memory as it gets
pretty fun.
PAVEL FELDMAN: [INAUDIBLE]
or not?
Did he close it?
PAUL IRISH: I think I have it.
PAVEL FELDMAN: So I
can go real quick
through the actual scenario.
So what you do is you
take a Snapshot.
And then you do a set of
sections that should result in
a zero sum, so that you create
something and discard something.
And you expect no objects to
be retained in the memory.
And then you compare those
Snapshots and see the deltas.
And if the delta is positive,
it means that objects with
corresponding classes are
still in the memory.
And expanding these classes and
clicking on the instances
will show retaining trees,
the retaining paths, the
JavaScript path that is
retaining this very object.
And depending on the version of
Chrome that you're running,
if you look at this list and
find detached DOM nodes row in
this very table--
do you have it there?
Try sorting by alphabetically
and going to the
detached DOM something.
It's a top-level entry.
No, you don't have it?
Try going from conversion to the
summary just for a second.
I'm bringing it up because
you can start with the--
do you have detached
DOM nodes?
PAUL IRISH: Yep.
PAVEL FELDMAN: So there's
a special row for
detached DOM trees.
And If you expect no DOM nodes
to be detached from your tree,
you start looking in here.
And if you see some, it means
that these are the DOM
fragments that are retained
by the JavaScript.
And that's pretty much the first
thing you do when you
find the memory.
Because all your DOM nodes are
either on the screen or in the
caches that you are aware of.
And Paul has shown the generic
Profiler capabilities.
But Browser is not
only JavaScript.
It is also DOM.
And those two are bound in
a sophisticated manner.
So to assess this binding and
see if there memory leaks on
the boundary between
the DOM and
JavaScript, you look in here.
SAM DUTTON: So just to get
that straight, a really
standard process for checking
for DOM leaks is, take a
Snapshot, do something, take a
Snapshot again, do comparison,
and then look for, what
is it, detached DOM
tree at that point?
PAVEL FELDMAN: Well, in the
generic case, you just look
for the class names
for [INAUDIBLE]
object in your model.
So if you are writing
a Gmail [INAUDIBLE]
conversation [INAUDIBLE], and if
you see an increase in the
number of threads or
conversations where you don't
expect it to, you start with
these large objects.
If you don't have any clue on
the large object of your
model, you start with the DOM
binding, because that's where
the probability of the leak
is extremely high.
SAM DUTTON: Thanks.
PAUL IRISH: So while we're
looking at JavaScript, I want
to show some of the new stuff
that we have for kind of
navigating around the JavaScript
that you have. I'm
going to bring up this page.
So over in the Scripts panel, if
you open it, you might see
something like this.
And in the left-hand side is
the Scripts Navigator.
And by default, it's in
a temporal state.
But you can click this to make
sure that it's always there
and permanent.
But below, you're going to see
all your active scripts on the
page sorted by origin
and folder.
And anything coming in from
your Chrome extensions is
going to be separated out now.
So it's a lot easier and cleaner
to see what's active.
ALEX SEXTON: Yay!
PAUL IRISH: It's great, yeah.
Another nice way to look through
any active scripts
that you have is hitting Command
O. So Command O will
bring up the Go To Resource
little navigator.
And I can type out any portion
of the file name and navigate
directly into that.
PAVEL FELDMAN: I think in
[INAUDIBLE] routines I think
you can do these [INAUDIBLE]
type first two letters,
[INAUDIBLE]
case large name, and
it will match it.
You don't have those because
[INAUDIBLE].
PAUL IRISH: Yeah, that's true.
Must have been a scripts
[INAUDIBLE].
And so within a script, so I
could beautify it down here.
And I get some sense, and
I can scroll around.
I can hit Command L and
go to a specific line.
But now I can also hit Command
Shift O and navigate by
function name.
So I can jump directly to my
siblings method of jQuery or
anything else.
So having this really easy way
to jump between my function
definitions saves quite a bit
of time in navigating your
scripts and then placing
[INAUDIBLE] points or doing
your debugging.
One of the things that I think
is also really nice when it
comes to JavaScript debugging is
being able to walk through
your code in a very large view
and seeing your page.
And so one of the new things
that you have in the Chrome
Dev Tools is the ability to
dock all the tools to the
right-hand side.
So now I can check that.
I'll even bring that back.
So now I have my page, my
code over on this side.
And I can work out exactly
what's going on, what the
behavior is.
Right beneath that
is Disable Cache.
And Disable Cache will disable
the disk cache.
So Chrome is actually very
aggressive when it comes to
caching, because it likes
things to be fast. But
sometimes as a developer, that
caching works against you.
So Disable Cache will just
bypass the disk cache.
So you're always getting
the freshest resources.
Pavel, so correct me if I'm
wrong, this cache affects only
this current page, because it's
only enabled when I have
the Dev Tools open, right?
PAVEL FELDMAN: Right.
PAUL IRISH: So if you have that
checked, you close off
Dev Tools, your cache
is now functioning
as it normally should.
So you have to have the Chrome
Dev Tools open for this to
take place.
ALEX SEXTON: I wanted to
interject a little bit.
One thing I do a lot in my
development is actually
override hosts and host files
and try to do local
development against
servers that way.
So I also have to clear often
my DNS cache and sometimes
even my socket cache.
And you can get to that through
the Chrome protocol
net dash internals and clear
it in the DNS there.
PAUL IRISH: Yeah, that's
a good one.
Go into About About, you can
see all the Chrome internal
diagnostics pages.
[? AV ?] cache internals is a
really good one where you can
remove any existing application
caches that you
have. Good if you're
doing offline work.
Net internals is a pretty
significant internal
diagnostic page where you can
see a lot of things going on
with sockets and DNS.
So it's a good call, Alex.
Should we take another question
from the Moderator?
SAM DUTTON: Yeah,
let's do that.
Let's have a look and see.
I'll tell you, today
was talking about--
let me just find the
questions here.
Let me just find the right
question from Pat in Auckland.
This question actually we were
asked today at a Dev Tools
presentation was, is there a
plan, something on the Dev
Tools roadmap to either directly
support or some other
way facilitate extensions,
which
allow less SASS debugging?
So Pat's thinking of something
like FireSass for FireFox.
Says I've heard about
source mapping.
But from what I understand,
that only applies to JS.
PAVEL FELDMAN: Yeah,
that is correct.
And we are currently not working
on last SASS support.
It's a bit more than source
maps for CSS.
Because what we would like to
see is actually your variables
here make sense on the
right-hand side So that you
can edit them as
in the source.
And they would take immediate
action in the browser, which
enables the transformation from
the source to the browser
terms and mapping things back.
So it's a bit more complex than
basically mapping the
locations in the minified
and non-minified script.
More work.
But as you probably know, WebKit
is moving forward with
supporting many of these
features natively.
And we will have no
option other than
supporting them in the UI.
And once they are in the UI, we
can think about supporting
the mapping.
But [INAUDIBLE].
PAUL IRISH: Yeah.
So there's been a spec published
on CSS hierarchies,
which is like your selector
hierarchy if you're
using SASS or LESS.
Also CSS Mixins, there's
a spec published.
And so WebKit is very interested
in baking that
right into the platform
as well.
But since we brought up
source maps, I was
going to show that.
This is source maps.
And the best way to demonstrate
what they do is
with this little demo.
So I have the small little
app with colors.
And as I click the colors,
we're just changing the
background.
This is easy enough.
If I view source of this app,
looks down at the bottom like
I commented out my original
source files, and I'm just
including my compiled JS, which
is a bunch of minified
JavaScripts.
So this happens a lot when
you're in a situation where
you are looking in scripts and
you open up compile.js, and
it's minified.
And you want to debug
what's going on.
Now I can beautify it.
But I still have short
variable names.
So that's not working
out to well.
But source maps give us
a lot of power here.
So if you notice down at the
bottom of this file is a
reference to source
map dot JSON.
Now if I bring that up.
So I think it's in
that JS folder.
So this is just a JSON file
which maps the identifiers of
the minified script back
to the original script.
And it's also referencing the
original source files.
So what this allows me to do
is instead of seeing this
compiled JavaScript here in the
Dev Tools, if I open up my
settings and enable
source maps--
I'm going to refresh the page.
And now, instead of seeing
compile dot JS, I see script
and set up and to my original
jQuery unminified.
So here I'm mapping my minified
JavaScript directly
back to my original files.
And I can set break points in
this and have it work exactly
like you want.
So this is the kind of base way
of looking at the future
of, I can take compiled
JavaScript and map that back
to my original source files,
however many there may be.
But source maps empower
a lot more than that.
For instance, CoffeeScripts--
being able to map your compiled
JavaScript back to
your Coffescript so that
you can actually debug
CoffeeScript right here
in Chrome Dev Tools.
Source maps enables this.
And there's a few patches
waiting on the CoffeeScript
project to accept.
And so hopefully we'll be able
to see real debugging instead
the Dev Tools of CoffeeScript
coming soon.
ALEX SEXTON: Does Google closure
advanced compilation
support source maps yet?
I know it's intending to.
PAUL IRISH: As far
as I know, yes.
I don't think I have this
available too much.
PAVEL FELDMAN: So we've been
working together with them on
the format.
And they are supposed
to [INAUDIBLE]
this format.
It's V3, so that's the one
we support in Dev Tools.
PAUL IRISH: And if you can read
this, this is kind of how
it works with the compiler.
So using closure compiler,
we run it.
We specify our original
source files.
We say that we want to
create a source map.
And we're going to use V3.
And then we're going
to output it.
And so this will generate the
source maps and get you off
looking in a good path.
DOM undo and redo.
Pavel, you added
this recently.
Do you want to walk us through
how this works?
PAVEL FELDMAN: Yeah, we should
all give it a try, do some
stress in it to see if it
is crashing or not.
Because it is a fairly
complex thing.
So the way it works is DOM
actions, editing attributes,
[? remaining ?] nodes, editing
as HTML Oracle undoable as
well as editing CSS properties
for adding new rules and
modifying selectors.
Pretty much everything you can
see in the elements panel
should be undoable
and redoable.
And when it does so,
it preserves
the DOM nodes instances.
So it's not simply installing an
old markup or a new markup
and loses all the [? page's ?]
state.
But it is doing it in a
[INAUDIBLE] manner so that all
the references to your nodes
from JavaScript will still
basically be valid.
And the other addition to that
is that edit as HTML is now
super smart.
When you're editing, you
can edit the entire
body of your page.
And it will only patch the
nodes that have changed,
preserving identities
of the other ones.
So we can open Gmail and edit
something in the body and
commit the edit and all
the threads are
still going to be alive.
And it's all undoable
and redoable.
PAUL IRISH: Right.
So if you have event handlers
bound to part of your nodes,
you can still come up and edit
this entire body as HTML.
Make your changes.
And your DOM nodes are
all still fine.
So pretty sophisticated stuff
going under the hood there.
A very powerful feature.
But what this manifest
says in an easy way.
So let's say I just want to
test some things out.
And I want to see what this
looks like without the H1.
I'm going to delete.
And that works fine, but maybe
I want to bring it back.
Just hit undo, like Command
Z, and bring it back.
Or Command Shift Z to re that.
So any changes that you make
here, Command Z to bring back
the original state.
PAVEL FELDMAN: And you
can also hit F2 to
start editing as HTML.
Because we know feel that it is
safer because it preserves
the states of the elements.
And we expect users to be using
it more often, because
it's super flexible.
PAUL IRISH: OK, one request.
Anyone watching, if you could
just hit a Plus One on the post
so we get an idea of how
many people are out there,
we'd love that.
And Sam, could you
introduce another
question from the moderator?
SAM DUTTON: Yes, indeed.
We've got one from Tony.
Says he's from cactus land.
Also known as Arizona,
I think.
He's asking if there are any
plans for the console to sport
auto-complete of elements
in the current page.
So he's thinking of things like
an element that has an ID
of, oh my God I don't
want to type this.
And he wants to attach say
a method by jQuery.
He's wondering if he could do
something like [? dial a ?]
parenthesis, quote, hash, ONG
and then it auto-completes.
So, sounds good?
PAUL IRISH: It sounded good.
Ah, so he basically wants
autocomplete based on the IDs
and classes that are already
active in the DOM and have
that available in the console?
SAM DUTTON: That's right.
Yep, I think that's
what he's after.
So whatever I guess is within
scope, so to speak, in terms
of ID or class.
PAUL IRISH: Yeah.
So right now we do have the
ability to autocomplete
anything in the console when
it's already available in the
DOM, so any of the functions
that you happen
to find in the page.
I love this a lot just to get a
reminder of what's available
on Window dot location.
And I forget the names of these
properties all the time.
One trick that you could do.
So let's say that document
dot body had an ID
of my awesome body.
Or it's a Window dot
document all.
This is a terrible idea.
I'm not suggesting
this at all.
It looks like we won't
get completion there.
SAM DUTTON: Nice try.
PAUL IRISH: I think that's
a good idea.
But right now we don't have any
capabilities of bringing
in new elements and
autocompleting your selectors.
PAVEL FELDMAN: But we
totally should.
So by [INAUDIBLE]
it should happen.
PETER BEVERLOO: The IDs are not
being autocompleted for
performance reasons right now.
Basically, trying to find an
element by its ID name instead
of an actual variable is quite
slow for the rendering engine,
for WebKit.
PAUL IRISH: Actually, I'm going
to go grab my USB cable,
because I have something
to show.
Pavel, do you want to run
through just the right way to
file a bug or feature request?
PAVEL FELDMAN: Can I steal
control over your machine or
how do you do that?
PAUL IRISH: You can screen
share on your side.
PAVEL FELDMAN: Can you
guys see this?
PAUL IRISH: Yep.
PAVEL FELDMAN: So we're running
a magic link that is
called
webkit.org/new-inspector-bug.
I'll need another browser.
Wait a moment.
So you need to be logged in.
So you need to register
at WebKit's Bugzilla.
And let me do it again
with another browser.
A moment.
SAM DUTTON: Just a quick
reminder for anyone who's
hanging out watching this.
You can view the different
screens by clicking on them.
So if you want to see Pavel's
screen or someone else's, you
can click on that individual
Hangout window down at the
bottom there.
PAUL IRISH: So is that better?
Can you see it now?
So that's the page the new
inspector bug brought me to.
So hold on.
I'm typing these web inspector
autocomplete--
[INAUDIBLE]
autocomplete something--
autocomplete DOM node
IDs and classes.
Name the console.
Then you describe what you want,
like you have document
body ID is [INAUDIBLE]
and you press FO and tab in your
console and [INAUDIBLE]
to expand to [INAUDIBLE].
And then you just
submit this bug.
And it goes straight
into my inbox.
And the reason I'm suggesting
to submit it into WebKit,
because whenever something is
happening within the Dev Tools
window, 95% of what is there
is being developed in the
WebKit repository
by our own team.
So what you do is you can either
file a bug against
Chromium, which will
totally work.
Or if you're confident it's part
of the Chrome Dev Tools
window, you just go ahead and
submit it into the WebKit.
So that's pretty much it.
PAUL IRISH: Thank you.
I did want to show some of a
new future that a lot of
people haven't seen.
And we're going bring up
some help for this.
SAM DUTTON: Just while you're
doing that, could I take
another question
from Moderator?
PAUL IRISH: Yeah, please do.
SAM DUTTON: Yeah, it's one
that people have asked.
Another question from
Pat in New Zealand.
He's asking if there's a way
to assist the break on
sub-tree attributes modification
breakpoint
functionality through multiple
page refreshes.
So trying to debug some
code at page load.
But currently, if you refresh
the page, it resets them.
So, yeah.
PAVEL FELDMAN: So it
is totally a bug.
It should preserve those.
There's a little hint, though.
What the tool is doing upon
page load, upon the unload
event, it will try to restore
all the breakpoints based on
the node IDs.
And if your DOM is dynamic or
if something has not yet
happened and the DOM is not
there and the node is not in
the DOM, the tool will
fail to do that.
But it will pick it up once
the node is there.
If this scenario does not work
for you, file a bug.
Otherwise it should
be just fine.
SAM DUTTON: Thanks, Pavel.
That's great.
PAUL IRISH: So I wanted to show
a really nice feature
that we just enabled.
And that is remote debugging.
If you haven't known, we shipped
Chrome for Android a
little bit ago.
And one of the great things that
we have available is that
you can actually have the full
power of the Chrome Developer
Tools, the sorts of things that
you've been seeing today,
available for your
mobile device.
So I'm just going to show
how this works.
I have my phone plugged in.
I also enabled USB debugging
inside the OS.
And I'm going just set up
an ADB port forward.
Great.
And now we're going to bring
up local host port 9222.
Cool.
So just to capture this.
So the six items up there refer
to my six open tabs
right here.
So I'm going to just go
back to Google News
and click it up here.
And so if you didn't know,
the Chrome Developer
Tools is a web app.
So I'm just running the Chrome
Developer Tools as a web app
inside Chrome.
But this is the actual inspector
of the page.
To show that, I'm just going to
hover over these sections.
And you should be seeing the
nice hover happen inside the
phone's UI.
So this is pretty powerful.
I'm going to go over to Console
just to prove that
we've got this going on.
Yeah, nice.
So full remote debugging
capability.
Things like your network timing,
the ability to run
Heap Profiles and get memory
debugging info on a phone is
something that we haven't
had available before.
And so now with Chrome on
Android, we have that full
capability.
And we're really excited about
what that offers to mobile
development.
ALEX SEXTON: You need a Ice
Cream Sandwich phone.
But you should all
get one anyways.
They're awesome.
PAUL IRISH: Peter, is
there anything you
want to add on that?
True, yeah, Ice Cream
Sandwich required.
Delicious too.
PETER BEVERLOO: Yeah, Ice Cream
Sandwich is required.
At lunch the other day
we had [INAUDIBLE]
of Chrome on Androids.
And of course, there's much
more [INAUDIBLE] coming.
PAUL IRISH: Nice.
So get excited.
Good stuff coming.
I think we could talk about
extensions, select a
profiling, show paint recs.
Anything, Pavel, that you think
we should point out?
PAVEL FELDMAN: So I could say
a few words on what we're
currently doing.
So Paul has mentioned
the [INAUDIBLE]
And let me list what we are
currently committed to doing
and are in progress of.
So we are paying a lot of
attention to mobile.
We are happy to see a remote
debugging story.
But you often want to be able
to have your mobile web page
from a desktop browser.
So what we're currently
working on is a more
sophisticated user agent
emulation that would allow
integrating screen resolution.
More native events that
would make sense
for the mobile device.
So that you could basically
conveniently [INAUDIBLE]
development for mobile.
We are currently working
on memory [? lot. ?]
So the Heap Profiler that is not
working on a Canary is not
working because we are redoing
the entire thing.
We want it to be simpler.
We want it to support
scenarios for memory
[? content ?] or generic
Heap information
capabilities and such.
So going full speed there.
We are also working on the
HTML5 features such as
IndexDB, which has been
recently landed.
It's still within the
experimental, but has good
chances of going public
in Chrome 19.
We are also focusing on the
game development stories.
And we are reworking our
timeline for better capturing
what frame is, what 16
milliseconds for frame mean
and what actually takes time so
that our clients would have
a way better clue on what needs
to be optimized, whether
it's pane layout or JavaScript
or garbage
collection or something.
And what else?
That's pretty much it And yes,
we are exploring different
persistence stories.
Paul, do you want to mention
a couple of extensions for
persistence?
PAUL IRISH: Yeah,
I would love to.
So if you've been editing your
styles, as you might have
seen, there is an ability to
get a [? dif ?] of your
changes and save the new
file back to disk.
But a lot of people have been
curious as if that little
path, that workflow could
be made automatic.
So there's been a little
bit of work in
that direction recently.
There's two extensions that I
would ask you to check out.
One of them, you can get a brief
view if you just Google
for Addy Osmani auto-save
dev tools.
And Addy's put out a nice little
screencast about how
this works.
But essentially, it's an
extra Chrome extension.
You make your changes.
You run a node server.
And it just saves the changes
that you're making into the
Dev Tools back to your
disk as you go.
There's another extension made
by a member of the Dev Tools
engineering team that has
similar functionality.
Just a different UI.
And right now, they're
talking about how to
merge these two efforts.
But if you want that kind of
functionality, definitely
check out one of those
two projects.
SAM DUTTON: That's great
to see, actually.
That covers questions we get
regularly at events and one
that's high up the list
on Moderator.
Just a reminder to people who
are watching this, if they
could Plus One the
page for this.
Because it really helps us
work out what kinds of
Hangouts people want.
So Plus One it if you could.
That would be great.
PAUL IRISH: There is a lot
happening in Dev Tools.
I just loaded up Canary using
a command line flag, Enable
Dev Tools Experiments, inside
settings that enables some
extra stuff going on as an
IndexDB, which Pavel was just
talking about.
Being able to see shadow DOM
inside elements panel, some
extra stuff.
So if you want to ride
the bleeding edge,
that's where it's at.
You can check out peter.sh for
the news on a week by week
basis of the entire Chrome
and WebKit projects.
But you'll get a lot of detail
on what's happening inside the
Dev Tools as well.
And I would also recommend
Canary
updates once a day, about.
And you can run it
side by side with
another Chrome instance.
So I really recommend running
Canary and Chrome
Stable side by side.
In Canary, you get the freshest
Dev Tools features.
But you get to hold on to Stable
to see what all your
users are seeing your
site and app as.
So I think that's it.
Anyone else have anything
they want to add.
No?
Cool.
I thank my guests
for joining me.
And we appreciate you
guys coming and
hanging out with us.
So thanks.